Speaking, by the way, of malignancies, this
is just hilarious. We've talked for years
about the debt and deficit being a
political football. Both Democrats
and Republicans throw the football back and
forth to some degree. Republicans do it more.
And Republicans claim to be about low deficits,
cutting the debt. When a Democratic president
is in the White House, but when all of
a sudden a Republican president is in,
they don't talk about it. George W. Bush exploding
the debt. Donald Trump exploding the debt. You get
a Democrat in the White House all of a sudden, oh,
infrastructure covered stimulus. If Biden wins,
you know, you will hear it. Well, how are
we going to afford that? Will deranged and
depraved Republican Senator Ted Cruz is taking it
a step further. Instead of saying the debt doesn't
matter, he's instead saying Trump never ran on
reducing the deficit or the debt. Now, of course,
Trump not only ran on it, Trump hilariously
promised to completely eliminate the national debt
by running huge surpluses during his first
term. He's done the opposite. He's run record
deficits. You have to see the video to believe it.
Listen to the audio. Here is Ted Cruz trying to
pull this on Jonathan Swan from a
forthcoming interview on Axios on HBO.
Jonathan Swan instantly fact checking him. And
Ted Cruz just has to come up with some other lie.
He said, you know, the deficit's the worst thing
in the world when Barack Obama is president. But
Donald Trump came in and, you know, we're not so
worried about that anymore. He's he's right, isn't
he? So, look, I'm very worried about the debt and
I'm worried about it under Trump. Now, to be fair,
Trump didn't campaign on cutting the debt.
He did. He said he's going to eliminate the
national debt. That is he also said something.
What is it? I'm the king of debt in 2016. Right.
So we actually have to look into this in
detail, because this is not merely Ted
Cruz being a buffoon. It is Ted Cruz being
a buffoon. But this is part of a bigger
sort of transition that many Republicans are
making in case Joe Biden were to win. What many
Republicans are doing is starting to pretend
to care about the deficit again so that if Joe
Biden wins and does a corona virus stimulus, they
can go back to we can't afford this. The debt,
the debt, the debt. Now, of course, Trump
did run on paying off the national debt.
He said repeatedly that his tax plan was
going to be so good and create so much growth
that we'd run a surplus and pay off the debt
within four or five years of him becoming
president. Here's Trump telling Hannity he could
do it in five years or maybe even in less time.
He can balance the budget very
quickly. But nothing in five years.
I think over a five year period and I don't
know, maybe I could even surprise you.
There's a ton of these clips. I won't
bore you with them. But then Ted Cruz,
when he's called out, says, well, you know,
Trump did also say he's the king of debt.
This is idiocy. This is idiocy. When Trump said
he's the king of debt, he wasn't bragging about,
I will increase the deficit. I'm the king of debt.
As far as growing the national debt is concerned,
what Trump was saying was, I'm the king of debt.
I know how to renegotiate the debt. I know how
to reduce it or restructure it, which he also
hasn't done as president. How pathetic is Ted Cruz
as far as the facts go to just get them in here?
We are putting a chart up for a video audience
of the total federal public debt
over time, which is you can see,
even aside from the massive spike at the time
of Corona virus, the debt was trending up faster
during Donald Trump than during Barack Obama's
presidency. And everything Ted Cruz says about
it makes no sense. So this is the same tired game
that's been played for decades. Democrat comes in,
slows down deficit growth. Sometimes like
Bill Clinton even generates a surplus.
Then Republicans come in and do something
insane to blow it up, like George W. Bush
invading a country that didn't even attack us.
Democrat comes back and Barack Obama slows down
deficit growth every time he wants to spend.
Republicans say, how are we going to pay for it?
Trump runs on eliminating the debt, blows
it up and incomes. Ted Cruz saying, well,
Trump never really ran on it. So, yes, both. Sides
play the debt deficit games. But Republicans are
the ones actually increasing the deficit. Like
no other. And Ted Cruz really needs to go as a
reminder. Now, sadly, he's not on the ballot
right now. He just won reelection in 2018.
He'll be back on the ballot in 2024. His
time will come. We can hope. We can hope.